i don't know i mean the golden globes
what is shocked that that's not
happening yes I sort of feel like the
Oscars won't go on or it will be
resolved before them I like that the
asker's would go on like the Golden
Globes where everything just becomes a
news conference what has been 88 does
anyone here know what happened with the
oscars in 88 when there's anyone alive
and 88 I was just a child I was toddler
my mother's me like who won the oscars
in 88 marty was it Marty it was like
sound editing in 98 um I think was that
was the year that Marlon Brando did not
take the ask Renee sent the Indian sash
Juan little feather Sacagawea
ratatouille no no I'm for Best Picture
I'm gonna say there will be blood I
would say there will be blood I agree
that I saw this one is a PS i love you
thank you yes I love you I don't know
that big winner I would say no country
for old men mm-hmm interesting oded yeah
you didn't has anyone seen that I mean
I'm the internet because and I the end
like it wasn't raised by the Akita ok
you get added that out but the dream
well when they all go in the hovercraft
when the whole thing was actually a man
in a snow globe yeah in the dream of an
autistic boy that was beautiful that was
beautiful oh I'm best actor who do you
guys think I think Javier Bardem is that
supporting actor made me yeah I thought
he was great he's really good in the
diving bell and the butterfly yeah you
look like I just gave something wait
everybody knows he's in that movie right
yes no he's a guy's guy who comes in and
he's like a murderer you guys knew that
right he's in that movie he breaks the
diving bell I haven't seen that movie
and and he sees dead people oh man hey
disembodied voice of God who do you
think is gonna win
Wow we are like Cassandra we can like
see the future but we can't change it
writer people don't believe us yeah we
are learning a different predictions
right which don't even internally agree
with ourselves individually um I don't
know historically the DGA does settle
yeah strike once that was like 37
seconds or something ya kid k minutes on
the west coast in three hours you could
look up on the internet I think it's
Huckabee and he takes a nation back for
Christ's isn't how could be the one who
thought that aids could be passed by
from mosquitoes he's lonely doesn't mind
to lock up people with AIDS yes he's a
really great I think it's pretty
hilarious that people um uh you know
don't read the issues further than like
a certain point like a lot of people
like I like him he's really funny he
plays the bass guitar or whatever and
Ziggy also you know has a son who kill
the dog and her wife who really man over
yes i agree with you i think that that's
crazy the people say that like mccain
has much more conservative than people
realize he's really conservative but be
more like he's so independent see me
huge war monger I love that in the times
of everyone talking about change the
Republican candidate could be a 72 year
old man who wants to stay in Iraq the
ultimate I think I think Huckabee when
the president you do know really
President of the United States oh my god
you will win or a president like that
the current president as a deal with the
president / you think he'll be President
do you really are you kidding no I think
I'm gonna sleep that is the scariest
thing I've ever there's a terrifying I
think he's very sick he's a very safe
governor of a southern state who will
will just be no he I think I think that
too many people would rally around
defeating him I think that you know he
did it surprisingly well in Iowa because
of the event della calls you noticed how
much the war has not really even figured
into the political discussion everyone
keeps talking about change and you know
but we're at war and that and it seems
like that would be something that would
be up like number one and that's barely
come up yeah as much as I'm it is boo
she hasn't been mentioned really at all
and like move from both sides you know
right although I really Huckabee is the
one who kind of he's distance himself
from bush and Romney said call him a
traitor for doing so he said the Bush
administration has made mistakes well oh
yeah he's also i think the closest to
bush in terms of like candidate like I
think he Jacobi yes I think he's like
almost Busch running I guess sort of
side of him and yeah and I think he
matches up a profile why's everyone is
as much a warmonger as Bush bush is you
know very hawkish oh no no yeah yeah I
guess I mean in terms of person like in
terms of background and stuff I do think
Obama should win I hope he wins yeah i
think obama has a pretty good job
you